tenants that are worried about eviction
are being urged to
take action when it comes to the new
eviction moratorium announced
this week by the governor this one is
different than past moratoriums put in
place
during the covid19 pandemic joe mohler
is live with
what exactly tenants need to know hi joe
yeah hey there brian well this new
moratorium is more similar to the one
that the cdc put in place and that was
set to expire at the end of this month
well unlike those other ones that the
governor had said earlier this year
this moratorium requires tenants to
print out a declaration and actually
give it to their landlord
i have a two-year-old and a
nine-year-old and i'm 32 weeks pregnant
stephanie edwards is in the process of
going to court over an eviction
the mediator gave us talked to her and
talked to us
and they gave us until next month on the
fifth to be out she hopes the new
moratorium will help her stay in her
home
the only place we can really go is if we
do get evicted is california back to my
parents house
sunday the governor announced a new
moratorium that will last through march
31st
tenants must take action the tenants do
need to
sign a declaration saying that they are
eligible for protection under the
directive this is what the declaration
looks like
it needs to be printed and given to the
landlord morgenshaw from nevada legal
services says if you make less than 99
thousand dollars a year
cannot pay rent due to a covert related
issue and are at risk of homelessness
you are protected there is no point
up to lockout that is too late so
even if you end up going to court
you can bring the declaration with you
to court you should not wait for a
notice to take action and always keep a
copy and proof you set the document
make sure that you're still applying for
rent assistance if possible
because this directive does not forgive
rent that's due
it doesn't stop rent stop late fees from
accruing
now if you wanted to find word find that
declaration online you can just head to
our website it newsnow and just
newsnow.com that is and click on this
story reporting live joe mohler good
news now